I'm dr. Julia Shaw a research associate
at University College London and the
co-founder of spot spot is the tool that
helps organizations tackle harassment
and discrimination with better reporting
options and better training and in 2019
along with dr. Camilla elphic and dr.
Rashid minus-- and a number of
international NGOs and charities we
conducted one of the largest studies
ever on witnesses of harassment and
discrimination at work
why witnesses the first time that I was
victimized and became the target of
inappropriate workplace behavior
I hadn't even left University a couple
of academics who were far more senior
than me repeatedly and relentlessly
targeted me and every time something
happens I wished that someone would
speak up that they would tell me that
I'm not overreacting that I'm saying
that there's something that we could do
but instead I found myself with
reporting paralysis I didn't speak up
and neither did most other people why
didn't I just speak up well I was
worried about the consequences for my
career because I loved my work I was
also worried about things that many
people see as barriers like not being
believed or taken seriously like my
situation resulting in no change
luckily over the past couple of years
we've seen that reporting paralysis is
affecting fewer people and some people
are able to now have voices - before
were voiceless when we first started
spot we allowed people to submit
statements about experiencing harassment
or discrimination to talk to spot.com
and as researchers we looked at these
stories and we were shocked when we
found that 93% of victims reported that
there was at least one witness these
things that aren't happening behind
closed doors
further research has since come out
which has further repeated this idea
that most harassment and discrimination
is witnessed and so how do we mobilize
these witnesses first let's talk about
the psychology of being a witness in
2018 two women were at a Starbucks when
they watched a barista deny access to a
washroom - two african-american men
instead the barista called the police
the two active bystanders took a video
of the men in handcuffs and posted it
online
this act of bystanding had an almost
immediate positive effect
Starbucks closed a number of its doors
and implemented bias training most of us
think that we would be these active
bystanders that we would be these kinds
of heroes in fact in research on this
when researchers give people
hypothetical scenarios and ask if they
would intervene most of us of course yes
of course of course I would stand up but
even when those same researchers present
an actual physical situation where
someone needs to actually intervene most
people do nothing and they fell prey to
the well-known bystander effect why and
what are the barriers that people are
facing in our research three-quarters of
people who we had interviewed and who we
had participate in our study which was
over a thousand participants
three-quarters of them said that they
never reported the incident to HR they
never reported the incident to someone
who could do something about it
and the barriers that they cited the
number one barrier was actually the
exact same as the main barrier that
victims report which is the fear of
consequences or retaliation even
witnesses are worried about what might
happen to them and their careers other
reasons that people reported was not
wanting to interfere or not wanting to
be a snitch not knowing they could
report or not knowing how all of these
things can be targeted with better
education and better systems in
workplaces but the story of the witness
isn't complete without also talking
about the consequences for the witnesses
themselves if you were to see someone
who had just witnessed a crime being
committed on the street you would almost
certainly go up to that witness and say
you okay do you need some support you
might even offer them counselling or
therapy to process what they just saw
but witnesses at work are largely
invisible and of course so is support
for them and some of this invisibility
might even be internalized when we asked
our participants about reporting and
when we asked them about the negative
consequences for them we found that most
people said when asked directly did
witnessing this experience have a
negative repercussion most people said
no I'm fine but when we looked at the
qualitative entries when we looked at
what people actually wrote about this
experience we found that these
experience have profoundly negative
impacts they increase stress and anxiety
and depression they increase the
prevalence of desire to leave the
organization loss of faith why is there
this discrepancy it seems that we're
doing a comparative evaluation compared
to the victim not nothing really
happened to me but that's not really the
right question and support shouldn't be
invisible just because you're less
affected because we're all affected and
we should all be supporting each other
we also found evidence of a social
contagion while 23% of participants told
HR more 46% told colleagues usually
someone on their team and 67% told
someone outside of work what this shows
is that the negative consequences of the
situation where someone is harassed or
discriminated against go far beyond the
room people take that story with them
and that discontent grows as they tell
more and more people and this has the
real effect that is almost certainly
threatening your ability as an
organization to retain and attract
diverse and excellent candidates so what
do we do to stop the social contagion
what do we do to reduce these barriers
and how do we provide support for
witnesses and victims how can we be
better allies and it's easier than you
might think in my research I've come
across five particular things that I
think every organization can and
do to help tackle this issue and to
build healthier workplaces first
showcase your commitment if your
leadership isn't repeatedly saying how
important diversity and inclusion is to
them and living by example no one is
going to believe you and the HR driven
campaign is insufficient your
organization is a direct mirror of its
leadership team and they need to be
setting the tone second train your
managers the main person who is likely
to harass someone in your organization
is a manager now why
perhaps because power corrupts or
perhaps because we promote people into
managerial roles because they're
excellent at their jobs and we assume
that they will pick up the people skills
pick up the management skills along the
way but then they don't and this
provides a fertile ground for harassment
and discrimination with unrealistic
expectations with poor time management
with poor conflict management skills
trainer managers third we know from
research on victims that without the
ability to report anonymously the fear
of consequences is so overwhelming that
most people will never report incidents
we found the same was true from
witnesses when we asked them directly in
our study whether organizations could do
something to improve the fact that they
might report they said number one that
they could do better was allowing for
witness anonymity second was providing
choices about who to report to perhaps
shockingly although managers are the
most likely person to be perpetrating
harassment or discrimination in many
organizations they're also supposed to
be your first point of contact when
things go wrong now that's a major
sticking point so being able to choose
who you go to is crucial third
encouraging witness reporting back to
setting a tone in your organization
saying you can and should report things
and you can help stand up for each other
for us even when you have all of this in
place most people will not speak to HR
we know this because it's spot we
thought anonymity would solve everything
it did not anonymity is one piece of the
puzzle conducting surveys means that you
go out to your employees you don't wait
for them to come to you and you asked
everybody about how they feel about the
health of I inclusion and diversity
efforts within the organization and be
specific ask people about specific
incidents or specific things they've
witnessed because just like in our
survey if you ask people directly if
they've experienced harassment or
discrimination the default answer is no
but if you ask about specific
experiences or specific behaviors most
people go oh yeah I saw that the other
week so making sure you ask the right
questions is crucial finally and most
importantly research shows that one of
the best ways to mitigate the bystander
effect is to build a shared social
identity it's not about policing each
other it's not about calling each other
out it's about being a cohesive unit we
are in this together if you attack one
of us you're attacking all of us because
wouldn't you on that wouldn't you want
someone to stand by you if something
negative happens we're all hopefully
collectively building an organization
that is stronger and healthier and more
diverse and inclusive without my allies
I wouldn't be here when I was first
targeted with inappropriate behavior at
work
I fell into a depression and I almost
left academia altogether without a few
people who stood by me I wouldn't be on
the stage right now and I wish I had a
happy ending for you but unfortunately
these individuals are still at it you
see in organizational structures where
colleagues work in dispersed way is
where it's difficult to know who even to
report to nevermind what the
consequences might be these kinds of
behaviors are most likely to flourish
for longer but that doesn't stop me from
trying to stop it and I can tell you one
thing that over the past couple of years
of my research I have found that there
have been so many positive changes
changes in legislation changes and
attitudes and organizations are finally
taking these issues seriously I swear
the time of the harasser z' and the
bullies and the discriminators is coming
to an end
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]